how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
at the end of Avengers in game we saw
Captain America go back in time to
return all of the Infinity stones and
then he stayed there a few seconds later
Bucky and Falcon noticed that there was
a man sitting on a bench on the lake not
too far from them and of course it was
Steve Rogers who revealed that he stayed
back in time and lived out his life
married to Peggy Carter and while he's
talking to Sam he gives him his shield
seemingly passing down the mantle of
Captain America to Falcon however
according to a recent report and a leak
it seems like we may be getting a new
Captain America that is not Sam Wilson
break it all down in this video but
first reminder I'm still doing my
giveaway at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers I'll be picking
three winners and each will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection to enter all you have
to do is be a subscriber leave a like
and a comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so like I said according to a
report and a leak it seems like Sam
Wilson aka Falcon may not actually be
the new Captain America at least not at
first when the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series starts it actually has not been
confirmed that Sam Wilson will in fact
take on the mantle of Captain America
captain simply gave him a shield and
according to Deadline Marvel Studios
hadn't mentioned that Sam Wilson will in
fact be taking the shield from Captain
America and Avengers in game but had no
comment on where it's going to go after
that and according to movie news Netcom
there is talk that indicates that shield
will recruit Falcon in the Winter
Soldier to go up against a terrorist
organization that threatens the United
Nations and it is said they will fight
alongside another agent named John
Walker who has been enhanced to have
abilities similar to Steve Rogers but he
progressively goes insane and they have
to stop him as well for those of you who
are not familiar with who John Walker is
in the comics he actually becomes
Captain America at one point and
according to a recent leak the Falcon
and Winter Soldier series will have a
new government-sanctioned Captain
America that is supposed to be John
Walker this could possibly be taking
from the comics because if it's true
that shield has recruited Falcon and the
Winter Soldier that means that Nick Fury
and probably Thunderbolt Ross will be in
the Falcon Winter Soldier series in the
comics when Steve Rogers gets a little
bit older and it's time to choose a new
cap
in America the choice is between Nick
Fury and Sam Wilson however they decide
to give the mantle to John Walker who
was the super Patriot at the time
because they felt that Nick Fury
wouldn't want to step down from being
the director of shield and they felt
that the United States was not ready for
a black Captain America but the leak
does say that Walker will progressively
go insane
so John Walker isn't exactly like Steve
Rogers when it comes to being Captain
America he's actually very brutal when
it comes to being Captain America and
fighting and in the comics his parents
end up being murdered and he goes
completely insane killing and critically
injuring many people now eventually he
would be okay and he would go on to
become US agent using an old Steve
Rogers Captain America uniform and his
disc shield and according to this leak
it seems like this could be the story
route that they're going to take Falcon
and Winter Soldier now ultimately in the
comics Falcon does become Captain
America so we could see John Walker be
Captain America for a little bit then he
goes insane and then after Falcon and
the Winter Soldier defeat him Nick Fury
names Falcon Captain America and John
Walker becomes US agent if these leaks
are true this seems to be the direction
that they're going with the series now
we have recently learned that Carrie
Skoglund is going to be directing the
six-part Disney Plus miniseries and that
Zemo and Sharon Carter will be returning
as well so there are really many ways
that they could take this series and
remember Kevin Feige said that these are
definitely in the MCU all of these TV
series will affect the movies that
happen in the MCU they are completely in
and connected to the MCU so whatever
happens in these shows coming to Disney
Plus directly affects the movies so
according to these leaks we will be
getting a new Captain America in the MCU
at least for a little bit until the
mantle truly falls on Sam so let me know
what you think about this leak in the
comments down below and again a reminder
about my giveaway at the 450,000
subscriber mark I'll be picking three
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection so be sure to subscribe to my
channel leave a like and a comment down
below so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Marvel and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
a congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you kill top of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your